and so Pinocchio is left without the
guidance of conscience and the cricket
is trying to figure out how to get off
Pleasure Island but he goes through the
gates and he sees what's actually going
on and what's going on is that the
coachman has this like slave boat down
in the bowels of the island and he's got
all these these black-suited minions
with the glowing eyes working for him
and they're rounding up what looked like
donkeys and so they're beasts of burden
right and so there's an idea here that
if you produce simple if you pursue
impulsive pleasure to the detriment of
the development of your character you're
going to end up a beast of burden you're
going to end up a slave to a tyrant and
that's exactly right and so anyways but
the cricket doesn't you can see one of
those black-suited Horrors here hauling
donkeys out of this crate and one of
them has a hat on and they look very sad
and they're in different crates and one
of them says sold to the salt mines and
one says sold to the circus and so
they're shipped off to be to be slaves
roughly speaking and they look very sad
and then one of them gets hauled out of
a crate and he still got to have he has
a hat on and a sweater and he can still
talk he's a boy it turns out that's been
half transformed into a jackass a
braying jackass prior to being enslaved
and so that's that's another thing
that's quite interesting about the story
you know it also makes the case that if
you replace your voice with stupid
braying that the probability that you're
going to become enslaved by a tyrant is
extraordinarily high and I always can't
help but think about idiot idiot logs in
that matter
you know Solzhenitsyn wrote about the
radical left ideologue that got thrown
in the Gulag Archipelago you know so
they were party stalwarts this happened
to a lot of people true believers who
are vacuumed up by this telling this
machine and through ninh thrown into the
gulag anyways and he said that those
people suffered in some ways more than
everyone else because What did he say
they were bit by the beloved ham that
fed them and so the first while when
they were in the camps Sojin isn't
really didn't know what to do with
like that because on the one hand well
they were in the camps and wasn't that
awful and they've been torn away from
their families and you know stripped of
all their identity and their status and
so that's pretty rough but on the other
hand they were writing letters
protecting their innocence and assuming
that everyone else in the camp was
guilty but they were innocent and they
were still strident believers in the
communist process and so you know it was
a conundrum here they are being terribly
punished but by the same token they're
also the perpetrators of their own
demise so how do you deal with them and
they used to play comrades he said they
used to play comrades with people like
that and invite them into an ideological
discussion about the camp situation and
the situation in the country as a whole
and let them rattle out their
ideological justifications for
everything that had happened in trying
to make them parody themselves roughly
speaking it was a rough game and
Solzhenitsyn also concluded that there
is no helping someone like that when
they were still in sconce tin side that
braying ideology you could predict
everything they were going to say it's
like someone had a crank he could just
crank it and out would come in the
proper ideological formulas but then he
realized that as soon as they let's call
it repented of that and started to
realize their their own role in it or
the error of the system then he would
start communicating with them you know
as if they were people who who you could
communicate with yeah so that was very
interesting as far as I'm concerned
anyways this kid is still a little bit
human he starts to cry for his mom and
the coachmen basically throws him back
into the crate and says that he's not
ready yet and the reason for that is
that he could still he still had the
power of independent speech you remember
right at the beginning of the movie when
the mouth was painted on Pinocchio we
saw that mask that was really glaring at
the process and I said that character
recurs continually throughout the movie
and there's a good example of that
because the coachman is the enemy of
anything that has its own voice so he's
the anti Geppetto that's a good way of
thinking about it he's a tyrannical
aspect of the
of the culture but insofar as one of
these mostly donkeys mostly jackasses
can still talk then they're not
completely fit for slavery
and you remember this movie was also
being made at about the same time that
the Nazi transformation of Germany was
taking place and so all these terrible
underground things you know this this
process whereby people were being
reduced to to ideological slaves say and
in this terrible process that was all
playing out in Europe in a very big way
and it's not like people weren't aware
of that you know within there so anyways
the the donkey's the jackasses that can
still talk or crying and complaining and
repenting and the coachman turns into a
full tyrant again in Crocs whip if I
remember correctly and says you've had
your fun and now you're going to pay for
it so the cricket gets word of all this
he gets wind of it he starts to
understand what's happened is that all
these bad kids were enticed out onto
this island so that they could be
enslaved and he's really taken aback by
that to say the least but he realizes
what's going on so he runs back to find
Pinocchio and then the scene switches
back to the eight ball bar where
lamp-wick is drinking beer and
complaining about what the conscience
said you know because he's kind of
guilty and ashamed but he won't admit it
because he doesn't admit anything he
knows everything he's not going to admit
anything about himself that isn't
perfect he's a real totalitarian in
training and he drinks this beer and
he's laughing about the conscience and
putting him down and then he says well
what what is why does he say exactly
what does he think I am a jackass or
something like that maybe that's not the
words exactly and then he grows these
these ears and Pinocchio sees that and
immediately takes a look at the beer and
stops drinking it and then lamp-wick
transforms one more time and his face
turns into the face of a donkey and he's
laughing still and then his his hands oh
yes he laughs and he starts to Bray like
a like a jackass and he's horrified by
that and then Pinocchio laughs
and the brain comes out as well and so
now they're absolutely horrified and
lamp-wick actually figures out what's
going on he figures out that he's being
tricked and that he's transforming and
he's completely horrified by it he
becomes conscious of what's happening to
him and there's one particularly I would
say dramatic scene where his hands have
transformed in hooves and he's kicking
and and and and leaping around the room
in panic and he comes up to a mirror and
sees himself as a jackass and then he
turns around and breaks the mirror so
you know he self-conscious for a moment
then he destroys his capacity for self
consciousness then he transforms
entirely into a jackass he's farther
down the road than Pinocchio and he
comes crawling to Pinocchio to save him
and asks that the conscience comes back
so that he can get out of this but of
course it's a bit too late and so then
an ochio grows jackass ears and he's
absolutely terrified by it as well he
knows what's coming and the cricket
comes back and and guides him off
pleasure island and so then they end up
on a cliff because this is an island
after all we have to jump into the
unknown right out of this impulsive
adolescent hedonic playground into the
unknown and that's how they escape